I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi, everyone. It is Money Part 2 today. Second half of money. Second half of money we got lost to cover. It's season four, episode eight, written by Paul Lieberstein, directed by Paul Lieberstein. Angela, I'm coming in hot today and I'm coming in right with a summary. Are you ready? Yeah. No banter. No banter at the top. Okay. Here we go. All
我是詹娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。大家好。嗨，大家好。今天是《金钱（下）》。《金钱》的下半集。金钱的下半集有很多内容要讲。这是第四季第八集，由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，保罗·利伯斯坦执导。安吉拉，我今天火力全开，而且直接带了剧情梗概来。你准备好了吗？准备好了。没有闲聊。开头没有闲聊。好吧。我们开始吧。好
right. In Money Part 1, we found out that Michael has money troubles. He had to take a second job as a telemarketer. Meanwhile, Pam and Jim visited shrewd farms, which Dwight has started operating as a bed and breakfast. And Andy serenaded Angela in hopes of winning her heart. Well, this week, Michael works with Oscar to try and get himself out of debt. Andy continues to pursue Angela and Kelly flunts her new relationship with Daryl in front of Ryan, who really just wants everyone in the office to use PowerPoint. PowerPoint. PowerPoint. Michael just thinks it's like a cheer from cheerleading camp. He's literally powerfully pointing his finger as he says it. Yep. All right. Well, fast fact number
了。在《金钱（上）》中，我们发现迈克尔遇到了财务危机。他不得不兼职做电话推销员。与此同时，潘和吉姆参观了精明农场，德怀特把那里改造成了一家民宿。而安迪则为安吉拉深情献唱，希望能赢得她的芳心。嗯，这周迈克尔和奥斯卡合作，试图摆脱债务。安迪继续追求安吉拉，凯利在瑞安面前大秀她和达里尔的新恋情，而瑞安其实只希望办公室里的每个人都使用PPT。PPT。PPT。迈克尔只觉得这就像啦啦队训练营里的口号。他说这话时，手指还在有力地指着。没错。好吧，那么第一个幕后
one, we mentioned last week that this was the first episode that was directed by Paul Lieberstein. What I discovered in my research this week, Angela, that he was nominated for an Emmy Award for directing this episode, his first episode. Wow. Where do you go from there? You're like, I crushed it. I'm done. Yeah, pretty much. Well, here's something crazy. He was up against Paul Feig, who was nominated for directing the season four finale, Good By Toby, but they both lost to Barry Sonanfeld for pushing Daisies. Oh, I mean, Barry is a fantastic director. I know. Well, dang it. We had a Paul versus Paul. Yes. Who would have won? I would have been able to choose between those two guys. Yes. Maybe better.
趣闻，我们上周提到过，这是保罗·利伯斯坦执导的第一集。安吉拉，我在本周的查阅中发现，他因执导这一集而获得了艾美奖提名，这可是他的第一集。哇。从那之后你还能去哪？你就像是，我太牛了。我大获成功。对，差不多吧。好吧，这里有个疯狂的事实。他的竞争对手是保罗·费格，后者因执导第四季大结局《托比再见》而获得提名，但他们俩都输给了《灵指神探》的导演巴里·索南菲尔德。哦，我的意思是，巴里是一位非常出色的导演。我知道。唉，真该死。我们迎来了保罗对阵保罗。是的。谁会赢呢？我本来无法在那两个人之间做出选择。是的。也许更好。
Maybe better, you know, for our sake, because it's about us. Maybe better. You know why? Because you know, rain would have made fun of the loser Paul. There would have been winner Paul and loser Paul. You know rain would have done that. You're so right. All right, lady. Fastback number two. This episode introduces the relationship between Kelly and Darryl. And I have to tell you, this was a very popular storyline with fans. Oh, people loved this. Loved it. I love it. Me too. I love how like no nonsense Darryl is and it spirals Kelly out. She does not know how to handle his just direct, honest, no game playing. Yeah. Well, it started a number of debates online. There was Kelly and Darryl versus Kelly and Ryan.
也许更好，你知道的，为了我们好，因为这事关我们。也许更好。你知道为什么吗？因为你知道的，雷恩会嘲笑那个失败的保罗。会有赢家保罗和输家保罗。你知道雷恩会这么干的。你太对了。好了，女士们。第二个幕后趣闻。这一集引入了凯利和达里尔的关系。我必须告诉你，这在粉丝中是非常受欢迎的故事线。哦，人们太喜欢这个了。超喜欢。我也很喜欢。我喜欢达里尔那种毫不废话的性格，这让凯利抓狂。她完全不知道该怎么应付他这种直接、诚实、不玩套路的态度。嗯，这在网上引发了不少争论。当时有凯利和达里尔对阵凯利和瑞安。
There was a very short lived Carol Carol mashup of Kelly and Darryl Carol with a K people made jokes who will last longer Carol or Carol. If you remember Michael's girlfriend, Carol. Oh, yes. So this was just really, really fun to see this relationship play out. It was mostly like a revenge date, I think on Kelly's part, but she also think you think I mean, she literally Darryl has a whole talking head where he says, you know, I get excited when I see the little dude come in the office because that's when she pays attention to me. But she also does seem like a little taken with him. But guys, the thing about this and a lot of people pointed this out online is like, finally, there's a man who's treating
还有一个短暂存在的凯利和达里尔的组合叫卡罗尔，名字带K的那种，人们开玩笑说到底谁能坚持得久一点，是卡罗尔还是卡罗尔。如果你还记得迈克尔的女友卡罗尔的话。哦，是的。所以看到这段关系的发展真的非常非常有趣。我想对凯利来说，这主要就像是一次报复约会，但她也——你觉得吗？我的意思是，达里尔甚至有一段单独访谈，他说，你知道的，当看到那个小家伙走进办公室时，我就会很兴奋，因为那是她开始关注我的时候。但她也确实看起来有点被他吸引了。不过伙计们，关于这件事，很多人在网上指出的一点是，终于有个男人在好好对待她了，而她却应付不来——她被戏剧性所吸引。她被瑞安吸引。瑞安也是如此。这是他们的走向没落的原因。我们会在好几季中看到这一点的发展。好吧，我们都知道这样的情侣。拜托，你肯定有这样一个朋友，她总是被那个把她生活搞得一团糟的家伙吸引，对吧？是的。反之亦然，对吧？男人们也是。没错。你会说，那另一个对你那么好的人呢？他们会说，不，我就想要那个让我发疯的人。是的，差不多吧。好吧，这一集里有很多精彩的凯利和达里尔的场景，但有一个被删减的片段我很喜欢。它发生在接近尾声的时候，但我会——我会——我会等到我们讲到那里时再说。但这可以说是凯利在试图
her well and she can't deal like she is attracted to the drama. She is attracted to Ryan. Ryan is as well. This is their downfall. We will see it play out over several seasons. Well, we all know couples like this. Come on, you have that friend who was always attracted to the guy that made her a total mess, right? Yeah. And vice versa, right? Dudes as well. Yep. And you'd be like, what about that other person who's so incredibly nice to you? And they're like, no, I want the person that makes McCrezy. Yeah, pretty much. Well, there are great Kelly and Darryl scenes in this episode, but there was a deleted one I loved. It happens towards the end, but it's I'll, I'll, I'll wait till we get there. But it's Kelly trying
弥补。哦，哦，听起来真不错。哦，我等不及要看那个了。好了，女士们。第三个幕后趣闻。安吉拉，我不知道你是否记得，就在我们拍摄这一集的时候，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在青少年选择奖上赢得了最佳电视剧男演员奖。不，我不记得了。好吧，你知道的，你会赢得一块冲浪板。奖品就是那个。那个奖杯是一个巨大的彩色冲浪板。现在，史蒂夫曾赢得过金球奖。是的。我们曾赢得过演员工会奖，但这次不同。我们的剧集曾获得过艾美奖。我们的剧集曾获得过艾美奖。但这就好像你已经进入了主流视野。这是一件大事，为了给你提供一些背景信息，以下是前几年获得史蒂夫这个奖项的历届得主。马特
to make amends. Oh, oh, that sounds great. Oh, I can't wait for that. All right, lady. Fast fact number three. I don't know if you remember, Angela, but right around the time that we were filming this episode, Steve Carell won Best TV actor at the Teen Choice Awards. No, I didn't remember that. Well, you know, you win a surfboard. That's the award. That's the award statue is a giant colorful surfboard. Now, Steve had won a Golden Globe. Yeah. And we had won the SAG award, but this was different. Our show had won an Emmy. Our show had won an Emmy. But this was like you've hit the mainstream. This was a big deal to give you some context. Here are the previous winners in Steve's category in the years prior. Matt
·勒布朗（《老友记》），阿什顿·库彻，威尔摩·瓦尔德拉玛（《那七十年代秀》），然后是史蒂夫获奖，再之后是乔纳斯兄弟获奖。我告诉你，这就像是史蒂夫是一位名副其实的明星。他是个巨星。我的意思是，如果连青少年都在为你投票，拜托。是的。嗯，我有点注意到，而且我觉得就在这个时候，对于我们《办公室》的所有人来说。我觉得我们的生活就是在这个时候开始改变的，我们即将进入我称之为我们的好莱坞岁月。我们开始经历最疯狂的经历。是的。我的意思是，我记得我当时正排队参加我们受邀的一个派对，站在我前面的是罗伯特·德尼罗和乔·佩西。是的。我正和那些家伙排队进
LeBlanc for friends, Ashton Kutcher, Wilmer Valderrama for that 70s show, then Steve one after that, the Jonas Brothers one. I'm telling you, this was like Steve is a bona fide star. He's a star. I mean, if the teens are voting for you, come on. Yes. Well, I kind of noticed and that I feel like right around this time for all of us on the office. This is when I feel like our lives started to change and we are about to enter what I am calling our Hollywood years. We started having the most crazy experiences. Yeah. I mean, I remember I was standing in line for this party we'd been invited to and standing in front of me are Robert De Niro and Joe Pesci. Yeah. I'm waiting in a line with those guys to get into
入一个派对。我记得我看着你，心想，现在到底在发生什么？詹娜，我记得在颁奖典礼季的一个派对上。布拉德·皮特也在那儿。哦，是的。还有安吉丽娜·朱莉。是的。还有莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥。就像，我不认识他们，伙计们。顺便说一句，我没有和他们任何人说话。没有。我吓坏了。我和詹娜、奥斯卡还有杰克·麦克布瑞尔在角落里跳舞。我们就这么做了。好吧，我只记得在这个时候，我不断打电话回家，把发生在我们身上的所有疯狂事情告诉我的父母。这也是我们开始上脱口秀节目的时期，还记得吗？那是一个全新的世界。我记得，安吉拉，你是《办公室》中第一个上大卫·莱特曼节目的女演员。哦
a party. And I remember looking at you and being like, what is happening right now? Jenna, I remember being at a party during the award show season. Brad Pitt was there. Oh yeah. And Angelina Jolie. Yeah. And Leo DiCaprio. Like, I don't know him guys. By the way, I didn't talk to any of them. No. I was terrified. I danced in the corner with Jenna and Oscar and Jack McBrayer. That's what we did. Well, I just remember at this time I was constantly calling home to tell my parents all the crazy stuff that was happening to us. And this was also when we started going on talk shows, remember? And that was a whole new world. I remember, Angela, you were the first female cast member of the office to go on David Letterman. Oh
天哪，你们不知道我当时有多紧张。我紧张极了。那天早上我甚至拉肚子了。分享得也太多了吧。我当时太紧张了。大卫·莱特曼人真的很好，他那里的整个团队都——就好像他们知道我快要吓尿裤子了一样。我当时太激动了。我是他的超级粉丝，以至于我妹妹拍下了电视上我在莱特曼节目的画面，我还把它框了起来。就像那是任何东西都还不上网的年代，你知道吗？是的。所以她拍下了我的电视屏幕。好吧，那真是一个疯狂的时期，而且，我非常感激能和你们一起经历这一切，因为我觉得我们对这一切都有着相同的反应。我们能受到邀请感到无比高兴。我们喜欢八卦我们看到的
my gosh, I was so nervous, you guys. I was so nervous. I had the runs that morning. Such an overshare. I was so nervous. And David Letterman was so like kind and his whole team there was so, it's like they knew I was about to poop my pants or something. I was so thrilled. I was such a fan of his that my sister took a photo of the TV of me on Letterman and I have it in a frame. Like that's before anything was like on the internet, you know? Yes. So she took a picture of my TV. Well, it was just such a crazy time. And, and I am so grateful that I got to go through all of that with you because I feel like we had the same reaction to all of this. We were so tickled to be invited. We loved to gossip with each other about
一切。然后第二天我们醒来，去了塔吉特百货，买了一些东西来做一个花环。然后我们的生活继续。完全是这样。哦天哪。是的。好吧，听着，当你觉得自己像一条离开水的鱼，而你回头一看，你最好的朋友也是同一条离开水的鱼时，你知道，你会没事的。你知道，就像那个豪华厕所，当时就像是，还记得它就像是一个简易厕所，但它是我见过的最豪华的简易厕所。你和我对此赞不绝口。我们为这个豪华简易厕所感到大惊小怪。我敢肯定当时人们会想，好吧，女士们。而我们却在说，里面有灯耶。是的。这是个惯例，当他们举办这些派对时，他们
everything we saw. And then the next day we woke up and we went to Target and we bought things to make a wreath. And our lives went on. Exactly. Oh my gosh. Yeah. Well, listen, when you feel like you're a fish out of water and you look over your shoulder and your best friend is that same fish out of water, you know, you're going to be okay. You know, it's like that fancy toilet that was like, remember it was like a porta potty, but it was like the fanciest porta potty I'd ever seen. And you and I couldn't get over it. We are geeking out over this fancy porta potty. And I'm sure people were like, okay, ladies. And we're like, it's got lights inside. Yes. This is a thing when they have these parties, they
会引进这些豪华厕所。你们别说话了。我们拍了照片。我们为此做了一本剪贴簿。哦天哪。里面甚至有一个陶瓷洗手盆，里面还放着音乐。记得不知怎么的，他们把音乐输送进了这个豪华简易厕所里。我从来没见过这样的东西。这就是我们记录下来的东西。与此同时，剧中的其他演员却在和布拉德·皮特举杯庆祝香槟。而我们却在给简易厕所拍照，而且说个没完。我们就像是，你们需要去看看的东西，我们今晚要在信里跟家里人说的东西就是这个厕所。我和我爸详细谈了那个厕所，他问我，你是不是得踩一个踏板？我说，是的，爸爸，但它还是很
bring in these fancy toilets. You guys stopped talking. We took pictures of it. We scrapbooked about it. Oh my gosh. It had like a porcelain sink and it has music playing in it. Remember somehow they funneled music into this fancy porta potty. I'd never seen anything like it. This was the stuff we documented. Meanwhile, like other cast members on the show are like literally toasting champagne with Brad Pitt. And we're overtaking photos of the porta potty and we can't stop talking about it. We're like, the thing you need to see, the thing we're writing home about tonight is this toilet. I talked in great detail with my dad about that and he was like, do you have a pedal you push? I'm like, yes dad, but it's still
豪华。哦天哪。当我们需要和简易厕所合影时，我就知道我们注定要成为朋友。我也是。好吧，听着，伙计们，我们接下来还会有更多故事，因为正如我所说，这确实开启了我们生活中非常奢华的一段时期，翻看我以前的照片和这些档案真的很有趣，我挑出了更多准备讲述的故事。哦，我等不及了。顺便说一句，每次你说我翻看了我的档案时，我不知道为什么，也许是因为我今天有点神志不清。我脑海中浮现的画面就像是《夺宝奇兵》的那个结局，在你的车库里的某处，你有着所有的这些箱子，然后你就像是一个开着小型起重机的人在……好吧，如果我能那么有条理的话，那就
fancy. Oh my gosh. I knew we were meant to be friends when we had to take photos with the porta potty. Same. Well, listen guys, we will have more stories coming up because like I said, this did kick off a very fancy part of our lives and it's been fun to go through my old photos and these archives and I've earmarked a few more stories to tell. Oh, I can't wait. By the way, every time you say I've gone through my archives, I don't know why maybe it's because I'm loopy today. I just picture you like in that final scene of Raiders of the Lost Ark that somewhere in your garage, you have all these boxes and you're like a little mini crane going. Well, if only I could be that organized, it would
是我的梦想成真了。哦，那你一定会高兴坏的。好了，我们要休息一下，然后回来深入探讨《金钱（下）》。好了，我们回来了。《金钱（下）》，我们从疲惫不堪的潘在前台的场景开始。她在打哈欠。吉姆在打哈欠。德怀特打着哈欠走进来。每个人都度过了一个艰难的夜晚，吉姆对德怀特说——我把这个记下来了，因为这正好印证了那个观点：当人们试图对德怀特或安吉拉好时，几乎总是会适得其反。是的。吉姆非常友好地对德怀特说，你还好吗，对吧？德怀特说，我比你过去好，也比你将来任何时候都好。给你来这么一句。给你来这么一句。好吧，
be my dream come true. Oh, you would be so happy. All right, we will take a break and we will be back to dive into Money Part Two. All right, we're back. Money Part Two, we're starting with the scene where a very tired Pam is at front reception. She's yawning. Jim is yawning. Dwight walks in yawning. Everyone's kind of had a rough night and Jim says to Dwight and I wrote this down because it just goes with that argument of when people try to be nice to Dwight or Angela, it almost always backfires on them. Yes. Jim very nicely says, you okay to Dwight, right? Dwight says, I am better than you have ever been or ever will be. There you go. There you go. Okay,
德怀特。好吧。是的。不仅如此，潘和吉姆刚刚住在德怀特的民宿里。这就是为什么他们很累。他们刚刚为他做了这件极其好的事情。但没有，这并没有赢得德怀特的一丝好感。他依然有一句刻薄的评论。不过听着，他们并不是唯一疲惫的人。安吉拉和迈克尔也因为打两份工而非常疲惫。他非常非常困。他在错误的日子里非常困，因为瑞安现在出现了。哦，是的。他正期待迈克尔做一个PPT演示。很快就很明显，迈克尔根本没有做任何准备。他完全不知道自己在干什么。瑞安质问了他。这就是我们发现的时候，或者说办公区的人们发现的时候，就是
Dwight. Okay. Yeah. And not only that, Pam and Jim just stayed at Dwight's B&B. That's why they're tired. They've just had this incredibly nice thing for him. But no, it has gained them no favor in Dwight's eyes. He still has a snarky remark. But listen, they're not the only people who are tired. Angela and Michael is also very tired from working two jobs. He's very, very sleepy. He's very sleepy on the wrong day because now Ryan has showed up. Oh yeah. He's expecting Michael to do a PowerPoint presentation. It's really clear very quickly that Michael has not prepared at all. It has no idea what he's doing. And Ryan confronts him. And this is when we find out, well, the bullpen finds out, right, that
迈克尔还有另一份工作。没错。瑞安告诉他，迈克尔，如果第二份工作影响了你在邓德米弗林的表现，你就不能做第二份工作。迈克尔对此作出了回应。伙计们，这把我笑得前仰后合。他说，面对现实吧，反正我也学不会怎么弄这个。是的。这太诚实了。太真实了。我只是被这种诚实逗笑了。太真实了。然后瑞安看向后排，看到了达里尔。好吧，他听到凯利在笑，那种为了让他看过来而发出的假笑。是的。他说，达里尔在这里干什么？离开这个会议。达里尔说，好吧，乐意效劳。哦，是的。这，我不需要留在这里。凯利说，好吧，那我待会儿见。而他说，
Michael has another job. That's right. And Ryan tells him, Michael, you cannot have a second job if it affects your work at Dunder Mifflin. Michael responds to this. You guys, it made me laugh so hard. He says, let's face it, I was never going to learn how to do this anyway. Yeah. Which is so honest. It's so true. I just laughed at the honesty. It's so true. And then Ryan looks to the back row and he sees Darryl. Well, he hears Kelly laughing, like forced laughter to totally get him to look over. Yes. And he says, what's Darryl doing here? Get out of this meeting. Darryl's like, fine, happy to leave. Oh yeah. This, I don't need to be here for this. And Kelly's like, okay, I'll see you later. And he's like,
我待会儿有安排。对她如此诚实，把我逗乐了。但我想让你知道，他们那个吻。是的。如果你看到20分35秒，伙计们，我截了图。约翰·卡拉辛斯基彻底笑场了。他在做那个搞怪的鼓腮动作，就是你笑场时试图把脸转开的那种。他正看着你，而且他快要憋不住了。好吧，安吉拉，如果你看的话，那是你，然后是约翰，然后是我。这在会议室里是绝对不允许发生的。你绝对不应该看到我们三个人排成一排。对，因为我有一种前倾身子、隔着约翰跟你说话的身体记忆。哦，而且我们三个人都会这样。我要把头转向另一边，因为我不能看着你们。我知道。就像我把身体转开了。约翰在笑，
I have plans later. So honest with her, it cracks me up. But I want you to know that smooch that they have. Yeah. If you go to 20 minutes, 35 seconds, you guys, I took a picture of it. John Krasinski is full on breaking. He's doing that weird puffy cheek thing when you break and you're trying to turn away. He's looking at you and he is losing it. Well, Angela, if you look, it is you, then John, then me. This should never be allowed in a conference. You should never see the three of us in a line. No, because I have a sense memory of leaning forward and talking to you over John. Oh, but also the three of us would go. I'm turning the other way because I can't look at you guys. I know. Like I've positioned my body away. John is laughing and
而你看起来就像是……是的。不，我记得整场戏里我们都一团糟。我们一团糟，但这场戏太精彩了。看完这场戏后，我给保罗发了短信，我说，保罗，这简直是完美。你知道的，他为了这场戏据理力争，就是这个“无论谁”的梗。是的。他据理力争。他太喜欢了。我喜欢会议室这场戏的每一个节奏。太搞笑了，安吉拉。他有告诉你我给他发过关于“不论谁”和“无论谁”的短信吗？没有，我甚至都没有——我只是发短信告诉他这简直是完美。我也做了同样的事。他告诉我，编剧室里曾就是否删掉这个桥段进行过投票。当时他承受了很大的删掉这个支线的压力。但他真的觉得应该保留下来。而且他很高兴自己坚持了下来，因为
you are like, look like you're on the verge. Yeah. No, I remember we were a mess during this whole scene. We were a mess, but this scene is so brilliant. After I watched the scene, I texted Paul and I said, Paul, this is perfection. You know, he fought for this scene, this whole whomever, whoever. Yep. He fought for it. He loved it. And I love every beat of this conference room scene. It's so funny, Angela. Did he tell you that I texted him about whomever, whoever? No, I didn't even, I just texted him and told him it was perfection. I did the same thing. And he told me that there was like a vote in the writer's room to cut it. There was a lot of pressure on him to cut that runner. And he really felt like it should stay in. And he's really glad he did because
那正是当年我们获得提名时，他们在演员工会奖上播放的片段。就是那个“无论谁”的场景。多酷啊？太棒了。而且它真的成为了经典小段落之一。另外，我也觉得——我知道你和我经常这么说，但《办公室》女士们的粉丝们，你们和我们一样热爱这部剧。我只是觉得，这种类型的场景在其他剧集里是绝不允许自由发挥的。它们会向电视台的压力或其他什么妥协。而这个超长的场景，我们在其中讨论“不论谁”和“无论谁”，在其他剧里是绝对不会发生的。我相信这一点。好吧，我们收到了很多关于这场戏的邮件。人们想知道它是怎么被放进这一集的。我要在这里向他们大声致谢。谢谢格蕾丝·H、
that's the clip they ended up playing at the SAG Awards when we were nominated that year. It was the whoever whomever scene. How cool is that? It's so good. And it's become truly like one of the little classic moments. And also, I just feel like I know you and I say this all the time, but Office Ladies fans, you love the show as much as we do. And I just feel like these kind of scenes were never allowed to breathe on other shows. They would succumb to network pressure or whatever. And this huge long scene where we talk about whomever and whoever, it just wouldn't have happened on another show. I believe that. Well, we got a lot of mail about this scene. People wanting to know how it managed to be in the episode. I'm just going to give them a shout out. Thank you Grace H,
阿莉玛·H和泰·欧文斯写信来讨论“不论谁”和“无论谁”。好吧，我有一个绝佳的方法来记住该用哪个词，是“whoever”还是“whomever”。是什么？我觉得非常简单。我读给你们听听。网上都有，你知道的，所以在世面上你能找到这些。但这是对我最有帮助的方法。准备好了吗？是的。“Whomever”是一个宾格代词，其用法类似于代词“him”、“her”和“them”。例如：把文件给部门里的whomever。所以如果你在脑海中思考，究竟是“whomever”还是“whoever”，你只需在脑海中说：“把文件给部门里的him（他）”或者“把文件给部门里的her（她）”。瞧，或者whomever，或者whomever。然而，“whoever”是一个主格代词，其用法类似于代词“he”、“she”和“they”。例如：
Alima H, and Ty Owens for writing in about whoever whomever. Well, I have a great way to remember which to use whoever or whomever. What is it? I think it's really simple. I'm going to read it for you. It's online, you know, so you can find this out there in the world. But it's what's always helped me. Ready? Yeah. Whomever is an object pronoun and works like the pronouns him, her, and them. For example, give the document to whomever in the department. So if you just are thinking in your head, is it whomever or whoever, you would just in your head say, give the document to him in the department or give the document to her in the department. See, or whomever or whomever. Whereas whoever is a subject pronoun and works like the pronouns he, she, and they. For example,
写下这首诗的whoever应该赢得奖品。你可以替换为：he（他）写了这首诗，并且应该赢得奖品。she（她）写了这首诗，并且应该赢得奖品。哦，你听出来了吗？所以，只要在脑海中把“whomever”和“him”、“her”、“them”联系起来，把“whoever”和“he”、“she”、“they”联系起来。我觉得这真的很有帮助。我心里稍微有一点“嗯”的感觉。但我认为这非常有用。你知道是怎么回事吗，我不得不说，这个语法点一直把我难倒。我总是主动避免使用这两个词。好吧，我觉得这非常有用。我在想，你刚才告诉我的是不是会成为我的一个转折点？在今年剩下的时间里，你将会听到我频繁地使用“whomever”和“whoever”，因为在46岁之后，我终于开窍了。就像是
whoever wrote this poem should win a prize. You could substitute he wrote this poem and should win a prize. She wrote this poem and should win a prize. Oh, do you hear it? So just attach whomever to him, her, and them and attach whoever to he, she, and they in your head. I thought that was really helpful. I'm feeling a little bit of a hmm. But I thought it's very helpful. You know what it is, I have to say, this one has just always stumped me. And I just actively avoid having to use either. Well, I thought that was very helpful. I'm wondering if what you've told me now is going to become the turning point for me. And for the rest of this year, you're just going to hear a lot of whomevers and whoever's from me, because it will finally clicked after 46 years. It's like the
老师教我怎么拼写“Wednesday（星期三）”的那一年，因为我总是拼错。然后她就说，只要写“Wednesday”。我就想，“Wednesday”。你知道我永远都拼不对哪个词吗？这是一个真正的挑战，尤其是当你成为新手父母时，那就是“diarrhea（腹泻）”这个词。我正想说，是不是“diarrhea”？是的，因为它是一个让人眼花缭乱的词。太难拼了。当你有了宝宝，你得经常给你的妈妈朋友们发短信提到它。是的，作为新手父母，腹泻确实经常出现。我在这上面很头疼。还有，“nausea（恶心）”对我来说也有点难。Nausea，nauseousness。Nausea里面就是没有C，只有USA。我不知道。我不知道。但“diarrhea”真的是，你知道的，一个棘手的词。是的，无论是得这个病还是拼写它，都没什么好体验的。
year my teacher told me how to spell Wednesday, because I kept spelling it wrong. And she was like, just write Wednesday. And I was like, Wednesday. You know what word I can't spell ever. And it's a real challenge, especially when you become a new parent is the word diarrhea. I was going to say, is it diarrhea? Yeah, because it's it's a confusing word. It's very difficult to spell. And you have to text it a lot to your mom friends when you have a baby. Yeah, you really do diarrhea comes up a lot as a new parent. And I have a hard time with it. Also, nausea can be a little bit difficult for me. Nausea nauseousness. Nausea is just not and see in a USA. I don't know. I don't know. But diarrhea is really, you know, it's a tricky one. Yeah, having it spelling it, none of it's great.
好了，我们要回到这一集中吗？是的，也许我们应该。好吧，迈克尔必须辞掉工作。你知道的，瑞安已经对他说过，你不能打两份工。这已经影响到这份工作了。所以迈克尔去找菲加罗先生辞职。这真是一个极好的场景。他的选角太完美了。迈克尔对摄像团队说，你们正在拍摄历史。是的，他不会——你知道的，他可不是轻易辞职的人。我喜欢菲加罗先生的回应。他说，你走之前把耳机消毒一下，随时欢迎你回来。而且他几乎连头都没抬。好吧，而且你知道的，我曾做过电话推销员，当我做这份工作时，我大概辞职又重新加入过三次。这是一个旋转门。他们不指望你能干多久。任何在办公室待了一个多月的人都被
All right, shall we get back to the episode? Yeah, we maybe should. All right, Michael has to quit the job. You know, Ryan has said to him, you cannot work two jobs. It's affecting this one. So Michael goes to Mr. Figaro to quit. This is such a great scene. He's so perfectly cast. Michael says to the camera crew, you are filming history. Yeah, he doesn't, you know, he doesn't quit things. I love Mr. Figaro's response. He says, you know, sanitize your headset before you go and you're welcome back anytime. And he barely looks up. Yeah. Well, and you know, I worked as a telemarketer, and I must have quit and rejoined this job three times when I had it. It's a revolving door. They're not expecting like longevity. Anyone who had been in the office for more than a month was
认为是资深员工。哦，是的。其实要在那种地方被解雇是非常难的。因为你得付出相当大的努力才行。确实如此。他在菲加罗先生手下推销的产品之一是减肥药利波菲林（lipofedrin）。是的。我查了一下。这不是真的，对吧？美国没有。等等，什么？好吧，我在奥地利的一个网站上发现它在售卖利波菲林。他们是以我们这一集的名字给它命名的吗？因为我不知道——我不知道。我挺确定的。听着，我对它一无所知，但我确实在奥地利的一个网站上找到了它。伙计们，千万别吃那个。再说一次，我们这档节目的搜索历史啊。就像是，安吉拉怎么会逛奥地利网站？好吧。回到办公室，安迪来到了潘的办公桌前。他真的很想让潘帮他撮合安吉拉，因为他的追求招数不管用了。等等。我有几句话要说。首先，在23分18秒时，你们会想，女士们，如果我知道某个场景里有人在打量我的屁股，我肯定会穿塑身裤而不是我的老奶奶内裤，因为在23分18秒时，安迪在打量我的屁股，而我扭着腰走过去，你们能看到巨大的内裤痕迹。听着，这就是现实。这只是一部纪录片。这是一部纪录片。我当时为什么不看看剧本然后说，“哦，对了，今天是他们拍摄安迪看我屁股的日子。他们会把镜头拉近到我的屁股上。也许我不应该穿压箱底的内裤，也就是洗衣日穿的内裤。”让我告诉你一件事。什么？我每天都穿洗衣日内裤。
considered like a senior employee. Oh, yeah. It was actually very difficult to get fired from those places. Like you would have had to try really hard. It's true. One of the things he's selling with Mr. Figaro is lipofedrin, a diet pill. Yep. I looked it up. It's not real, right? Not in the US. Wait, what? Okay. I found a website in Austria that says it's selling lipofedrin. Did they name it after our episode? Because I don't, I don't know. I'm pretty sure. Listen, I don't know anything about it, but I did find it on a website in Austria. Don't take that, guys. Again, our search history for this show. It's like, what is Angela doing on an Austrian website? Okay. Well, back in the office, Andy has gone up to Pam's desk. He really wants Pam to set
好吧。你知道为什么吗？因为它们他妈的舒服。而且你知道我白天在努力当个女老板、把事情办妥的时候不需要什么吗？是不卡档。我不需要卡档。我不需要内裤绳卡在屁股缝里，只为了当我走来走去时，人们看不到大腿上的痕迹，好让他们知道——哦，天哪，我今天穿了内裤。为什么女性总是不得不掩饰我们穿了内裤这一事实？谁在乎你能不能看到我们每天都在穿的内裤在屁股上勒出的痕迹？惊不惊喜。我显然站在你这边。我显然穿着老奶奶内裤。我只是说，如果我早知道时间流逝中，我屁股走过的那组镜头会（你知道的）成为特写，也许——也许我那天会挑选另一条内裤。
him up with Angela because his moves are not working. Hold up. I have a few things to say about this. First of all, at 23 minutes 18 seconds, you would have thought, ladies, if I knew a whole bit of a scene with someone checking out my ass that I would have worn Spanx and not my granny panties because at 23 minutes 18 seconds, Andy's checking out my butt and I sashay by and you see big old panty lines. Listen, that's reality. That's just, it's a documentary. It's a documentary. Why didn't I look at the script and say, oh yeah, today's the day they shoot Andy looking at my butt. They're going to zoom in on my butt. Maybe I shouldn't have the bottom of the barrel undies, the laundry day undies. Let me tell you something. What? I wear laundry day undies every day.
不。我只想说这些。我为你勒出的内裤痕迹鼓掌。我觉得你这很有女老板的风范，也很有女权主义者的做派。女士们，骄傲地展现你们的内裤痕迹吧，因为你们穿着舒服。你们的屁股被覆盖了。你们的女性部位被覆盖了，而且你们在把事情干漂亮。你知道那道内裤痕迹说明了什么吗？说明了什么？我才不在乎。那道内裤痕迹说明：我有更重要的事情要操心，而不是去管你当我走过时怎么看我的屁股。这就是它所传达的。口袋和内裤痕迹就是我所代表的立场。好吧？那么我们继续往下讲，因为我们对此充满热情，但安吉拉对安迪的招数毫无反应。你们猜他的招数是什么？我知道。他从
All right. You know why? Because they're f-ing comfortable. And you know what I don't need in my day while I'm trying to be a boss lady and get things done? Is a wedgie. I don't need a wedgie. I don't need a string of panty up my butt just so that when I am walking around, people don't see a line on my thigh that lets them know that I'm, oh, shocker, wearing underwear today. Why do women always have to disguise the fact that we wear underwear? Who cares if you see a line on our butt from our underwear that we're wearing every day? Surprise. I'm clearly on your side. I clearly wear granny panties. I'm just saying, if I had known forever in time, the shot of my ass walking by was going to, you know, be featured, maybe, maybe I would have picked a different pair that day.
会计部旁边倒着走过去十次。真希望能看到那一幕。我知道。我希望我们有那段幕后花絮。我知道。好吧，有很多被删减的场景，他有一整条非常搞笑的支线，讲他是如何试图追求安吉拉的。他实际上走到会计部，邀请她去初中的JV长曲棍球锦标赛。那算是一个挺搞笑的场景。但随后他去找了办公室里的每个人，不仅仅是潘，向他们诉苦，而且他分享的内容有点不合时宜。我让山姆剪辑了两个片段。山姆，你能放一下第一个片段吗？听着，你们是我在这个办公室里最亲密的朋友。彼此彼此。正因如此，我来——管好你们自己的事。我得了相思病和发情病，快要死掉了。那是不可能的。除非你指的是淋病。
No. That's all I'm saying. I applaud you for your panty line. I think it's boss lady of you and feminist of you. Ladies, display your panty line with pride because you are comfortable. Your butt is covered. Your lady bits are covered and you are getting sh-t done. You know what that panty line says? What? I don't give a sh-t. That panty line says, I have more important things to worry about than your viewing of my ass as I walk by you. That's what it says. Pockets and panty lines are what I stand for. All right? So moving us along because we're very passionate about this, but Andy says Angela's not responding to his moves. Guess what his moves are? I know. He moonwalked past
我说的是安吉拉。好吧，所以他去找了吉姆和德怀特。他并没有就此罢休。现在，菲莉丝也卷进来了。山姆，你可以放那个片段吗？我全身都在起安吉拉水痘，痒得要命。哦，天哪，你真的得了淋病。嘿，安迪，也许这就是那种你必须跟她做一次才能把她从你体内排出去的情况。少管闲事，你。菲莉丝！菲莉丝！搞什么鬼，菲莉丝？哦天哪。我知道。这些都在被删减片段里。DVD上这一集的被删减片段真的很不错。好吧，我不知道你们有没有注意到，有一些观众写信来——马特·C和杰西卡·埃尔南德斯说，当安迪向潘征求关于安吉拉的建议时，埃德·赫尔姆斯是被指导那样站立的吗？你知道他们在说什么吗？哦，当他几乎要做成
accounting 10 times. Would have loved to seen that. I know. I wish we had B-roll of that. I know. Well, there's a lot of deleted scenes and he has a whole runner that's very funny about how he's trying to court Angela. He actually goes over to accounting and invites her to a JV LaCrosse tournament at the junior high. And that's kind of a funny scene. But then he goes around to everyone in the office, not just Pam, and hits them up and is kind of inappropriate with what he's sharing. And I had Sam pull two clips. Sam, will you play the first one? Look, you guys are my closest friends in this office. Right back at you. And as such, I come to- Stay in your business. I am dying of love sickness and horny sickness. That isn't possible. Unless you mean gonorrhea.
劈叉的时候？是的。是的，太恶心了。不，伙计们，那只是埃德·赫尔姆斯本人。埃德只是做出了那个选择，这把我逗笑了，我笑场了好几次，因为非常搞笑。他只是试图达到潘的视线水平，这是一个非常非常搞笑的选择。在DVD评论音轨中，珍·索拉塔和保罗·利伯斯坦谈到了这样一个事实：珍原本把安迪写得很甜美，你知道的，就像是在试图追求安吉拉，然后保罗把安迪写成了一个只想和人上床的家伙，这里面有一种融合，但他们说这行得通。行得通。就像安吉拉有时可以非常nice，但有时他又是个彻头彻尾的笨蛋。是的。好吧，我在这场戏里注意到了一个细节。在23分58秒，我称之为绳编手链警报。哦。安迪的手腕上戴着那种航海绳编手链。
I'm talking about Angela. Okay, so he's gone to Jim and Dwight. He doesn't stop there. Now, Phyllis gets involved. Sam, will you play that one? I am itching all over with Angela Pox. Oh my god, you do have gonorrhea. Hey, Andy, maybe this is one of those situations where you just have to do her to get her out of your system. Stay out of this, you. Phyllis! Phyllis! What the hell, Phyllis? Oh my gosh. I know. That's all in the deleted scenes. It's a really good batch deleted scenes for this episode on the DVD. Well, I don't know if you noticed, but we had some people write in Matt C and Jessica Hernandez says, when Andy is asking Pam for advice about Angela, was Ed Helms directed to stand like that? Do you know what they're talking about? Oh, when he does almost the
这在80年代非常流行。我记得人们戴过。你记得吗？嗯。好吧，我必须了解更多。所以我对这些绳编手链做了一次微型深度挖掘，以下是我发现的内容。你发现了什么？这叫土耳其头手链。它是一个水手结，根据“神秘绳艺”网站的说法，它传统上由一根单股绳索制成，然后自身加倍环绕，纽波特的船长们经常让他们的船员佩戴相配的手链，以便码头管理员在他们接近码头时认出他们。据说水手们佩戴这些手链是为了擦去额头上的汗水，有时他们会把这些手链作为好运礼物送给远在家乡的挚爱。但
split? Yes. Yes. So gross. No, you guys, that was just Ed Helms. Ed just made that choice and it cracked me up and I broke several times because it was very funny. He's just trying to get to like Pam's eye-to-eye level and it was a very, very funny choice. In the DVD commentary, Jen Solata and Paul Lieberstein talk about the fact that Jen had written Andy very sweet, you know, like trying to court Angela and then Paul wrote Andy just trying to get laid and there's this like kind of mix, but they said it works. It's it works. It's like Andy can be really nice, but then he's also just such a tool sometimes. Yes. Well, I noticed something in this scene. At 23 minutes, 58 seconds, I'm calling it rope bracelet alert. Oh. Andy is wearing one of those nautical rope bracelets on
我觉得这对于安迪来说是一个非常契合的选择，因为他是个水手，戴这个很合适，不过我们并没有过多地谈论它。这只是稍作暗示。我的意思是，这在后面的几季中会更多地展现出来，但我认为这是一个放置得非常巧妙的细节。是的。他们谈论的事情之一——我不记得那是哪个DVD评论音轨了，但埃德和迈克·舒尔谈到了他们为安迪的造型投入了多少心思，因为他属于那种东海岸预科生、喜欢航海的群体，他们确实精心打扮了他。他的领带与其他人的不同，他佩戴的配饰。那个水手的手链。是的。你是这么叫它的吗？水手结。水手结。是的。所以现在迈克尔要
his wrist. They were very popular in the 80s. I remember people wearing them. Do you remember that? Yeah. Well, I had to know more. So I did a tiny deep dive on these rope bracelets and here's what I found out. What did you find out? It's called a turks head bracelet. It is a sailor's knot and according to the website Mystic Knotwork, it is traditionally made of a single strand of cord that is then doubled up upon itself and captains in Newport would often have their crew wear matching bracelets to help the dockmaster recognize them as they approach the dock. It's also said that sailors wore these bracelets so they could wipe sweat from their brow and they sometimes made them as good luck gifts for their loved ones back home. But
去找凯文，因为他需要钱，而且他知道凯文赌博，他想知道凯文是否有内幕消息可以压注一场被操纵的比赛。迈克尔基本上是在描述一部电影，对吧？是的。是的。他更详细地描述了为什么某人会故意输掉一场比赛，而凯文则说，不，我不认识黑帮的人。于是他转向奥斯卡，说他需要一笔预支薪水。但这里还有一个被删减的场景，本该出现在这里：他在饮水机旁找菲莉丝要钱。那场戏极其尴尬，让人脚趾抠地。它在被删减片段里。好吧，这引发了奥斯卡和迈克尔之间精彩的你来我往，奥斯卡开始指导迈克尔，或者说试图帮迈克尔理财。哦，太棒了。他们在DVD评论音轨里稍微谈到了这个动态是如何产生的，迈克·舒尔说他们当时在寻找没有被充分利用的角色。他们觉得还没看够奥斯卡，而且他们喜欢奥斯卡总是那么务实，而迈克尔却那么不理智。所以他们觉得这是利用奥斯卡这个角色的好时机。太棒了。真的很好。我喜欢我们剧集这一点，我们有着深厚的人才替补席，编剧们会思考：哦，我们可以把谁凑成一对？我们有一段时间没听到谁的声音了？这周我们应该把谁的历史或故事推到前台？这总是能产出我最喜欢的故事情节。我也是。这是一种非常体贴的写作方式，对吧？就像他们会审视
I thought it was such an appropriate choice for Andy since he is a sailor for him to be wearing, but we don't really talk about it much. It's just been hinted at. I mean, it's going to come out much more in later seasons, but I thought this was a very well placed detail. Yes. One of the things they talked about, I can't remember which DVD commentary it was, but Ed and Mike Scher talked about how much thought they put into Andy's look because he is sort of that East Coast prep school goes sailing, you know, kind of crowd and that they really dressed him. His ties are different from the other guys and his accessories he has. That's Sailor's bracelet. Yeah. Is that what you call it? Sailor's knot. Sailor's knot. Yeah. So now Michael is going
剧集的宏观全景以及角色的不同化学反应和动态。我太喜欢奥斯卡和迈克尔了。被删减片段里还有很多没有播出的内容。但看他们互动真的太有趣了。好吧，说到有趣，凯利要去达里尔的办公室给他下最后通牒。哦，她想知道你今晚有什么安排？而他说，我打算把整个晚上陪我女儿。然后她就说，好吧，行，选我和你女儿。而他非常就事论事地说，呃，我女儿。好吧，我们收到了很多关于这场戏的邮件，这是一个有趣的现象。凯蒂·鲍曼、凯尔西·坎迪夫、莎拉·埃利斯和布兰妮·麦克马洪都说，无论是达里尔的办公室还是菲加罗先生的办公室，墙上都贴着一张传单，上面写着“特里餐厅”。这是斯克兰顿真实存在的地点吗？是的，是的。你查过吗？因为我查过，我也注意到了。我也注意到了。而且，那是一张黄色传单。所以非常显眼，很吸引眼球。好吧，首先，传单上的电话号码是正确的。哦，不。所以，现在还在营业。你打过电话吗？我没打，但我觉得也许我们今天应该打一个。现在？我不知道。好吧。为什么不呢？山姆，你能给特里餐厅打个电话吗？哦，天哪。我们要说什么？我们完全没商量过。特里餐厅，有什么我可以帮您的吗？你好。我们是电视节目《办公室》的詹娜·费舍和安吉拉·金斯利。我们正在重温这部剧，在《金钱》那一集里注意到了特里餐厅的传单。我们只是想打电话来打个招呼。嗨。你们知道你们的餐厅上节目了吗？真的吗？真的有人打电话吗？有来自世界各地的人打电话来。哦，天哪。请问您怎么称呼？黛西丽。黛西丽。很高兴认识你。打电话的人都会说什么？就是，这真的是一家餐厅吗？这真的是特里餐厅吗？我在看《办公室》。哦，天哪，黛西丽，你对此已经是老手了。好吧，非常感谢黛西丽今天花时间跟我们聊天。我们不想耽误你的工作，但今天的特色菜是什么？你们有每日特色菜吗？我们今天的超值特价午餐是啤酒面糊鳕鱼，配一碗汤、薯条、凉拌卷心菜和塔塔酱。哦，那是我们的招牌特价。
to approach Kevin because he needs money and he's like, you know, he knows Kevin gambles and he's wondering if Kevin has like any in on a fixed fight. Michael basically describes a movie, right? Yes. Yes. He goes into way more detail about why someone would like throw a fight and Kevin's like, no, I don't know anyone in the mob. So then he turns to Oscar and he's like, I need an advance. But there's also a deleted scene that would have come here where he hits up Phyllis at the water cooler for money. And it's so awkward and cringy. It's in the deleted scenes. Well, this just starts this amazing back and forth with Oscar where Oscar is going to start coaching Michael or trying to help Michael with his finances. Oh, it's so good. They talked a little
去找凯文，因为他需要钱，而且他知道凯文好赌，就想看看凯文有没有什么打假拳的内部消息。迈克尔基本上是在描述一部电影，对吧？是的。是的。他花了更多细节去解释为什么有人会故意输掉比赛，而凯文却说，不，我不认识黑道的人。于是他转向奥斯卡，说我需要预支薪水。但这里还有一个删减片段，他本来会在饮水机旁向菲利斯要钱。那段真的超级尴尬。它在删减片段里。好吧，这就开启了奥斯卡和迈克尔之间一段精彩的互动，奥斯卡开始指导迈克尔，或者说试着帮迈克尔理财。哦，太棒了。他们稍微聊了聊
bit on the DVD commentary about what brought this whole dynamic up and Mike said that they were looking at characters that hadn't been utilized. They felt like they hadn't seen enough of Oscar and they loved how Oscar was always so pragmatic and Michael's so irrational. And so they thought this would be a great time to utilize the character of Oscar. It's so good. It's really good. I loved that about our show and that we had this deep bench of talent and that the writers would consider. Oh, who could we pair up? Who haven't we heard from him in a little while? Whose history or story should we bring to the front this week? It always ends up producing some of my favorite storylines. Me too. It's a very thoughtful way to approach writing, right? Is like they would look
DVD评论中谈到了这种动态是如何形成的，迈克尔说他们在寻找那些没有被充分利用的角色。他们觉得奥斯卡的戏份还不够多，而且他们很喜欢奥斯卡总是那么务实，而迈克尔却很不理性。所以他们觉得这是利用奥斯卡这个角色的好时机。太棒了。真的很好。我喜欢我们剧组这一点，我们拥有深厚的人才储备，编剧们会去思考：哦，我们可以把谁凑成一对？我们有一段时间没听到谁的声音了？这周我们应该把谁的历史或故事摆在台面上？这总是能产出我最喜欢的故事情节。我也是。这是一种非常周到的创作方式，对吧？就像他们会审视
at the big picture of the show and the different chemistry of the characters and dynamics. And I love Oscar and Michael. There's a lot more in the deleted scenes that didn't make it in. But it's just so fun to watch them. Well, speaking of fun to watch, Kelly is going to go to Daryl's office and give him an ultimatum. Oh, she wants to know what are your plans tonight? And he says, I'm spending the evening with my daughter. And then she's like, okay, fine, me or your daughter. And he's just really matter of fact is like, uh, my daughter. Yeah. Well, we got a lot of mail about this scene, but it was an interesting thing. Katie Bowman, Kelsey Cundiff, Sarah Ellis and Brittany McMahon all said in both Daryl's office and in Mr. Figaro's office, there is a
节目的全貌以及角色的不同化学反应和动态关系。我非常喜欢奥斯卡和迈克尔。删减片段里还有很多没有播出的内容。但看他们互动真的太有趣了。说到有趣，凯莉要去找达里尔的办公室，给他下一个最后通牒。哦，她想知道你今晚有什么安排？他说，我要和女儿共度夜晚。然后她说，好吧，要么选我，要么选你女儿。他非常冷静地说，呃，我选女儿。好吧，我们收到了很多关于这场戏的邮件，这是一个有趣的事情。凯蒂·鲍曼、凯尔西·坎迪夫、萨拉·埃利斯和布里塔尼·麦克马洪都说，在达里尔的办公室和菲加罗先生的办公室里，都有一个
flyer on the wall that says Terry's diner. Is this a real place in Scranton? Yes, it is. Did you look it up? Cause I looked it up because I noticed it too. I noticed it too. Also, it's a yellow flyer. So it's very like it catches your eye. Well, first of all, the phone number on the flyer is correct. Oh no. So, and still working today. Did you call it? I didn't call it, but I thought maybe we should call it today. Right now? I don't know. Okay. Why not? Sam, can you call Terry's diner? Oh my God. What are we going to say? We haven't talked about this at all. Terry's, may I help you? Hi. This is Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey from the TV show, The Office. We're rewatching the show and we noticed Terry's diner flyer in the episode,
然后我们还有一些午餐特价和晚餐特价。听起来棒极了。黛西丽，请代我们向那里的所有人问好。不好意思，有这么多人总是打电话。谢谢你们这么配合，表现得这么好。没事，没关系。没问题。好的。祝你剩下的时间过得愉快。祝你过得愉快，黛西丽。好的。再见。再见。再见。好吧，就是这样。哦，天哪，她太可爱了。人们总是打电话来。来自世界各地。来自世界各地。哦，天哪。也许我们的道具部门当时应该把电话号码涂黑的。现在我真的好想吃那个超值特价午餐。不过好吧，回到这个场景。达里尔对凯利说不，他选择了他的女儿，对吧？她被气走了。她离开时做了一个W和一个L的手势，然后还做了一个抹脖子的动作，詹娜。是的，我查过这是什么意思。意思是“管他呢，输家去死吧”，对吧？大家的共识是这样。是的，我的意思是，凯利，他惹恼了她，所以她要带着一些戏剧性离开。好吧，回到楼上的休息室。大家都在八卦迈克尔的财务危机。今天成了八卦室了。今天休息室成八卦室了吗？我觉得今天休息室里全是八卦。休息室里的热辣八卦。好吧，我不知道你们有没有注意到，现场对人员进行了非常小心的走位安排，因为迈克尔进来时不能看到潘。所以你躲在角落里，而在你和迈克尔之间站着凯文。所以迈克尔进来时在讨论两个人，而潘正
The Money. And we just wanted to call and say hi. Hi. Did you guys know that you're diners? Do you really? Do people call? We have people that call all from all over the world. Oh my gosh. And what is your name? Desiree. Desiree. It's so nice to meet you. What do people say when they call you? Just, is this really a diner? Is this really Terry's? I'm watching The Office. Oh my gosh. Desiree, you're like old hat to this. Well, thank you so much, Desiree, for taking time to talk to us today. We don't want to keep you from your job, but what is the special today? Do you have a daily special? Our blue plate special for today is beer batter cod with a cup of soup, fries, slaw and tartar sauce. Oh, that's our blue plate.
这家餐馆。我们只是想打个电话打个招呼。嗨。你们知道你们是餐馆吗？真的吗？有人打电话来吗？我们接到来自世界各地的电话。哦，天哪。请问你叫什么名字？德西蕾。德西蕾。很高兴认识你。大家打电话来时都说些什么？就是，这真的是一家餐馆吗？这真的是特里的店吗？我在看《办公室》。哦，天哪。德西蕾，你对这种事都习以为常了。好吧，非常感谢德西蕾今天抽出时间跟我们聊天。我们不想耽误你的工作，不过今天的特色菜是什么？你们有每日特色菜吗？我们今天的特色招牌菜是啤酒面糊鳕鱼配一小碗汤、薯条、凉拌卷心菜和塔塔酱。哦，这就是我们的特色招牌菜。
Then we have a few lunch specials and dinner specials. Well, that sounds fantastic. And Desiree, will you please tell everyone there we say hi? And I'm sorry so many people call all the time. We appreciate you guys being such like good sports. Nope, you're, that's fine. No problem. Okay. Have a good rest of your day. Have a good day, Desiree. Okay. Bye. Bye. Bye. Well, there you have it. Oh my God, she was so lovely. People call all the time. From all over the world. All over the world. Oh my gosh. Maybe our props department should have like blacked out the phone number. And now I really want that blue plate special. But okay, back to this scene. Daryl has told Kelly no, he chooses his daughter, right? She's kicked off. She leaves
然后我们还有一些午餐特餐和晚餐特餐。听起来太棒了。德西蕾，你能告诉那里每个人我们向他们问好吗？很抱歉那么多人老是打电话。我们很感激你们能这么配合。不，没关系。没问题。好的。祝你今天剩下的时间过得愉快。祝你有美好的一天，德西蕾。好的。再见。再见。再见。好了，情况就是这样。哦天哪，她太可爱了。人们总是打电话来。来自世界各地。世界各地。哦天哪。也许我们的道具部门应该把电话号码涂黑。现在我真的很想吃那道特色招牌菜。不过好吧，回到这场戏。达里尔对凯莉说不，他选择了他的女儿，对吧？她被甩了。她离开了
and she does like a W and an L and then like a knife across the neck, Jenna. Yeah, I looked up what this meant. It means whatever loser die, right? That's a consensus. Yeah, I mean, Kelly, he's crossed her and she's gonna leave and, you know, with some drama. Well, back upstairs in the break room. Everyone's kind of gossiping about Michael's money troubles. It's the gossip room today. Is it gossip in the break room? I think it's gossip in the break room today. Hot gossip in the break room. Well, I don't know if you noticed, but there was some very careful staging of people because Michael has to enter and not see Pam. So you're standing tucked in the corner and then in between you and Michael is Kevin. So Michael comes in is like talking about two and Pam's
然后她比划了一个W和一个L，接着还在脖子上比划了一个切喉的手势，珍娜。是的，我查了一下这是什么意思。意思是“管他呢，输家去死”吧？大家意见一致。是的，我是说，凯莉，他惹恼了她，她要离开了，而且带着一些戏剧性。好吧，回到楼上的休息室。大家都在八卦迈克尔的财务危机。今天成了八卦室了。是休息室在八卦吗？我觉得今天休息室里全是八卦。休息室里的热门八卦。好吧，我不知道你们有没有注意到，现场对人员的走位做了非常精心的安排，因为迈克尔进来时不能看到帕姆。所以你躲在角落里，然后你和迈克尔之间站着凯文。所以迈克尔进来的时候在谈论二，而帕姆就在
sex life. And then Kevin walks away revealing Pam and lady, every time it happened and Steve would get that look of awareness in his eyes, it would make me laugh. You were going to make me laugh. It was so funny. And then Michael denies that he's having any money problems and to prove it, he gets out a $1 bill and he just crumples it up and puts it in his pocket. Would you do that if you were having money problems? Would you? And everyone calls him out on it. They're like, wait, you just put it in your pocket. Well, guys, it was originally written in the script that Michael would rip up the dollar bill. But then we found out when we were filming that that's actually against the law. Yeah, you can't do that to money. Yeah, you can't. It's illegal to deface US currency
to the point at which it's rendered unusable. And by the way, we wouldn't have just done it once. We would have had to do multiple takes. We would have committed multiple crimes in shooting the scene if we had ripped up that dollar bill. Well, I actually think it's funnier that he crumples it up and puts it in his pocket. I think that's a funnier joke. I do too. I think that was a good thing. After this break room, we have some fantastic Kelly and Daryl, some Carol. We got some Carol coming up. Yes. And Daryl has a classic line in the scene. Oh, I know exactly what you're talking about. All right, say it. He says to Kelly, Hey, I like you. What's not to like, but you need to access your uncrazy side. Access your uncrazy side went like viral. It's a good line. And then Kelly
has this amazing talking head where she says, Daryl is the most complicated man she's ever met. I mean, who says exactly what they're thinking? What kind of game is that? Yeah. What kind of game is he playing where he just tells me exactly how he feels? What the hell? She can't believe it. Well, coming up, we have a little fun piece of trivia because we have Creed and Oscar in the kitchen with Michael. This sounds like a game of Clue, right? It does. We have Creed and Oscar and Michael in the kitchen. Yes. And Creed is offering Michael some financial advice. He talks about how he needs to file for bankruptcy. Yes, he says bankruptcy is nature's do over. Thanks, Creed. And then Creed has a talking head where he explains that he just transfers his debt
to William Charles Schneider and he holds up a passport. And the passport says the birthday is February 8th, 1943. Now, February 8th is Creed's birthday. So I caught that right away. Yeah, guys. William Charles Schneider is Creed Bratton's real legal name. That is his birthday and he is holding up his actual real life passport. I just can imagine Creed being like, guys, I'll bring in my passport and they're like, okay. Well, I texted Creed about it and he did in fact bring in his real passport for this scene. Amazing. And he said that after the first take, Greg said, Creed, you might want to just cover up your passport number with your finger because that's a real legal document. Yes, Creed. So Creed did. Creed held it up in such a way that you could see some
of the information, but not the rest. So amazing. Amazing. Well, I want to say also, Angela, in this kitchen scene, I noticed another flyer this time for Sal's Pizza in Scranton. This is also a real place, we're not going to call it, but it was founded by two brothers, Sal and Nick Lupoli in Salem, New Hampshire. Their Scranton location is now closed, but I will tell you they are the home of the famous 19 inch three pound pizza. Dang. And you can still get it in New Hampshire, but the Scranton location is now closed. I have more pizza info for you. Oh, okay. Buckle in, fan catch from Megan Smith. At 28 minutes, 26 seconds, you can see a flyer for City Slice Pizza. Okay. This is also a real pizza place in Scranton and it is right near the University of Scranton
campus. Megan would like you to know that she used to work there as a pizza delivery driver, and their Buffalo Chicken Pizza is incredible. Lady, this got me wondering. Oh, God, I'm in, I'm in. What is the best pizza in Scranton? We talk about the pizza in Scranton on the show. We have flyers for pizza in Scranton on the show. I had to know. I feel like this is like when you go to the South and you ask someone, where's the best barbecue, you will get like 10 incredibly passionate answers. You are correct. Okay, let's hear it. According to TripAdvisor, the best pizza in Scranton is a little pizza heaven. Okay. According to Yelp, it's Marconi's Pizza House. And incidentally, Yelp rated a little pizza heaven number two. Alfredo's, which is featured on our
show, was number three on Yelp and number four on TripAdvisor. But it is in the top five. But when I consulted two local blogs written by residents of Scranton, they both declared that the number one pizza in Scranton is Vincenzo's Pizzeria. So there you have it. Okay. I think, Angela, when we go on our trip to Scranton, we should try all these pizzas and decide for ourselves. We should do that. We should also go to Poor Richards. And now we need to go to Terry's Diner, which is actually in Musick. Listen, we've got a whole like Pennsylvania tour ahead of us. We are going to eat our way through Pennsylvania, clearly. Okay. I can't wait. I can't wait either. This is going to be a fun trip. It really is. Okay. Well, I really need to
talk about Michael's talking head that's coming up. Lady, before we leave the kitchen, I just have to say one more thing. Okay. Why did Creed have a sugar dish positioned right in front of himself on the edge of the table during this entire scene? It's so odd. He does not have a cup of coffee or tea. He has no food. But for whatever reason, he has moved the sugar dish right in front of him. Check it out, everybody. Maybe he had a spot on his shirt and they didn't have time to change it. And he just started hiding it with the sugar dish. That's my theory. I wonder sometimes because Creed would make choices and scenes that were very random and very funny. And maybe there's some improv that happened that got cut out. I don't know. But it was very obvious to me that
for some reason the sugar dish ended up there. It's a mystery. Yeah. Okay. Let's talk about Michael's talking head because it's pretty amazing. Okay. Well, I have labeled this talking head. Here's your damn spinoff. So Creed has told Michael that declaring bankruptcy is this do-over. It's like going in the witness protection program. Michael lights up like a Christmas tree. He has a talking head where he says he's always wanted to be in the witness protection program. He's even already picked out his other name, his other identity. Are you ready? He is Lord Rupert Everton. He is a shipping merchant who raises fancy dogs. I need to see it. There's your damn spinoff. Michael Scott pretending to be a shipping merchant who raises fancy dogs. It's a must see.
I would watch that. And you know they would probably like put him in Arizona, not near any water, but he's a shipping merchant raising fancy dogs. And he legally changes his name to Lord Rupert Everton. Peacock. Peacock. Are you listening? Peacock. This leads to one of the most famous moments on the office when Michael enters the bullpen and loudly declares bankruptcy. And Jenna, it was so hard not to laugh and I knew I couldn't laugh because I was standing on a stool at the supply closet. Yeah, they moved you over. I am right by him. Yes. Well, we had a question from Hannah Yen who had the idea for Michael to yell, I declare bankruptcy in the bullpen. Guys, this was a pitch from writer Lee Eisenberg. He told me that when he pitched the line,
he actually performed it for Paul. And he'll never forget it. Well done. Well done, Lee Eisenberg. But yes, just classic line, so fun. And by the way, Steve did a little play on that for our New Year's message where he declared happy new year. He did. Just warmed my heart. I know me too. Well, you guys, I declare a break. I love it. Yes, I declare a break as well. We'll be back to break down the second half of this episode in just a moment. All right, we are back. Oscar and Michael are in the conference room and Oscar is going through all of Michael's financial records. We are really going to get some insight into where all of Michael's money is gone. Well, you know, Jenna, leading up to the scene, there was a deleted scene where Michael
is begging Oscar to sort of go through his finances with him. And Oscar does not want to do it. He's like, no, I'm not going to do it. And Michael says, if you help me with this, I will pay you $4,000 in coupons, credits, and backups, or I'll give you $5,000 cash. And Oscar's like, I'm starting to see how you got in this situation. It's interesting because at the beginning of Money Part One, it's sort of implied that Jan is the root of Michael's financial problems, that she's doing this renovation of the condo and she's spending a ton of money. She got a Porsche. They got a Porsche. But as we see in this scene, perhaps Michael has contributed to some of these problems. They certainly don't help each other out because in deleted scenes,
Oscar also lists some of Jan's expenses. Oh, well, good. Yeah. Good. Because it did seem like she was a big part of this problem. Oh, she is. Well, in this scene, we find out that Michael spent $125 on the best of the Muppet Show DVD. I looked it up on Amazon. I could not find this DVD. I don't know if anyone cares, but I looked it up. I couldn't find it. I found a lot of other box sets, but none of them were $125. I looked up the Core Blaster Extreme, so did I, which Michael spent $1,200 on. Yes. Could not find that either. I couldn't find it either. But you know what? It's so believable that this contraption would exist and that he would spend that money on it. Well, Michael says the Marine Corps uses this, and it's where they got the core in their name.
It's from the Core Blaster Extreme, even though they don't spell it the same. Exactly. Michael is having a very hard time grasping the gravity of this situation, and ultimately, Oscar encourages Michael to call Jan. Yes. He does not want her to know his money problems. And Kevin, by the way, also agrees with him. Yeah, let's keep our money problems away from the women. Kevin. Kevin. Well, meanwhile, over an accounting, Andy is about to give Angela a present. Yes. Andy gives Angela this cat that he says he found by Vance for Frideration. Now, we had a lot of people write in about this and say that they believe this is the same cat that Dwight gave Angela. Garbage. They believe it's garbage. And you know what? I stand corrected. I think they're right. I stand corrected as well.
We wondered about this a few episodes ago. Yes. This is totally meant to be garbage, which is now going to be renamed Bandit. That's right. Who you will eventually throw in the ceiling will get there. Who will live in my drawer? So crazy. So yes, guys, thank you for writing in. You're right. We are watching this in real time, everyone. Yes. So we now agree with you. Here's something kind of interesting. If you watch the DVDs, the DVDs have like little screensavers, you know, if you go to like commentary or deleted scenes or bonus features, there's little screensavers. For this episode, there's a very cute DVD screensaver of a little cat poking its head out of the box and meowing with Andy's dialogue. I'll put it up on Office Ladies Pod.
Now, what I don't know, Angela, is if we used the same cat actor, it looks very similar and it seems just as sort of like weirdly, snugly and comfortable in your arms as it was in Reigns. Weirdly, snugly, comfortable. No. Wanting to climb us like a tree and catapult off our head. So I think it's the same cat because that cat wanted to leap through the air off of me using me as a diving board. I think it was anticipating a future episode where it would be. Where it would have to fly in the air. No, I guess what I'm saying is we set this up as some sort of feral cat, but it clearly is just fine being around humans. If it can crawl and jump off them. Yes, there you are. Well, listen, Dwight is clocking all of this interaction between Andy and Angela. He has to go
out by the dumpster and play his recorder. He's so depressed. So depressed. He's playing You Give Love a Bad Name by Bon Jovi. I know. He's not in a good place. He's not in a good place. Jim and Pam notice and they want to try to make him feel better. So they write their glowing review of Shroop Farms on Trip Advisor. The coveted Trip Advisor. He seems to like it. And Pam is really genuine. Pam's like, we really did enjoy our stay. She means it. She does. You know, again, the thing we've been pointing out that Pam is Dwight's best friend. Pam may not know that, but you can see time and again where Dwight would see Pam coming through for him. Yeah. Michael has managed to get Jan on speakerphone and he's going to tell her about their money
troubles. And she does exactly what he feared. She's like, how could you? Yeah, she's disappointed in him and she's judging him and he can't take it. He runs away. What's interesting in this scene is there is sort of a whip pan to the window and you see this train going by outside and then it whips back into the scene. Well, I want people to know that the actual window in the conference room where Oscar and Michael are having their scene, that's a window to nothing. That's a window to a painted screen. Right. On the other side of the painted screen was our craft service table with our snacks. Yes. They're in a warehouse. So they did one of those little magical cuts here where they went up to Paul Lieberstein's office and they whipped to the window and out Paul Lieberstein's
writing office. There really was a train yard and there really were trains that went by. Yes. And what they had to do was they would cut in the middle of that whip such that you couldn't tell and they inserted that little shot of the train going by because that did not actually happen in the scene because it was impossible. That is absolutely true. Every day we drove to work, down Sadakoi, we passed a gunnery, we passed a crematorium, and we passed a working train like tracks and a junkyard and a junkyard dog. All of that was right there. And all of that was out Paul Lieberstein's window. A room with a view. And it was like just a freight train. There was not a passenger train. You know what I love about this is that the view from the writer's rooms was
actually like woven into this episode and I just kind of love that. I used to say that if we were ever confronted with an actual zombie apocalypse in real life while working on the office, we'd be in a great position because we could head over to the gunnery, arm ourselves, and then hop the train. Yes. It just felt like, you know, a good spot to be in should zombies suddenly overrun the world. Listen, I know there's no zombies in it, but I'm pretty sure John Wick would agree. He'd have his gunnery, he'd have some transportation. Jenna, I finally watched all the John Wick movies like you told me to. You watched all of them? What are you talking about? You told me to go watch them all. You said you have to see the John Wick movies. What are you talking about?
What are you talking about? I said watch Keanu Reeves movies. Like, no, you told me speed and the matrix. Hold up, lady. You told me to watch the John Wick movie. You said you, Sam, Sam. No, I, Sam, guys. For taking this to court, you did very excitedly. This has come up multiple times. You told me to watch John Wick. How attractive he is in the movies. Lady, how many are there? There are three. I've seen all three in a fourth one's coming out. I did a marathon of them. Okay, here's the thing. I spoke passionately about my love of Keanu Reeves movies, how they were getting me through the pandemic. I watched the first half of the first John Wick movie, but we couldn't finish it all in one night. Now, listen, I loved it.
Look at my face right now. I loved the coins. I loved how he had his coffee cups on a little towel next to his coffee machine. And Lee and I started doing that because we were inspired by what we saw in the John Wick movie, but we didn't finish it. Shut because, you know, we rented it and then the rental ran out. Shut the front door. You gave me this whole call to action, which by the way, now that I know you haven't even finished the first one, now it makes sense to me why you went on and on about that towel by his coffee mug because you never see that again. That's like five seconds. And then it's nothing but ass kicking for three movies. Listen, there's no more coffee mug. His whole house burns down. They blow his house up.
So now it makes sense to me. And I said, I watched it with Josh. I was like, Josh, we have to watch John Wick. Jenna said we have to watch it. And then I'm looking for the coffee pot. And I'm like, why is she talking so much about this coffee pot? Now it makes sense. You've only seen like 20 minutes of the movie. I saw the whole first half. Here's where I ended. He's been really injured after a big fight at that weird club where all the, you know, assassins constantly goes to a rave. A gazillion assassins always are at a rave. Yes. And he gets really wounded. And then that doctor like shoots him up with adrenaline and he should definitely be resting. And he's about to go out and do more ass kicking. And I was tired and I was worried for him. You know, I told you
I don't like it when people who have injuries continue to injure themselves. I needed a break. Well, then you might as well not watch the rest because he literally gets stitched up and then people punch him in his stitches. And also he is running. He is limping through like Rome or somewhere. Rome? How does he get to Rome? Second movie, second movie. And I literally turned to Josh and I said, you know what I can't handle right now is if he gets hit by another car. And literally three seconds after I said that, a car runs over him and sends him flying in the air. Sorry. That was a really long tangent for us guys, but mouth a gape. I am now the John Wick expert. How the hell did that happen? Well, I feel like I should watch them. Well, I think you should.
I think I will. But get ready because there's a lot of wound on wound. I don't like seeing wound on wound. Well, it's hard for me. Okay, I don't know. Where are we? Well, here we are. Angela walks over to Andy. She's holding the crazy cat and she says, you may ask me out to dinner. Yes, she says nothing fancy or foreign, no bars, no patios, no vegetables and no seafood. What's up with no vegetables? I don't know. She's a vegetarian. What does she eat? Are you going to eat what rice pasta? What will you eat? My cauliflower spaghetti. That's a vegetable. I know. Cauliflower spaghetti. Hold the cauliflower. She's not going to make it easy on Andy for sure. Well, Dwight is crushed. He runs to his stairwell.
This is where he goes to pump himself up or maybe where he goes to deal with sad feelings. This is his, I guess, little spot. This is his emotional nook. Yeah. And Jim follows him. He tries to comfort him. And it's really sweet because he kind of talks about his relationship with Pam and his own heartbreak. Listen, you know, I watched this episode three times. And the first time I watched it, I was like, oh, that's so sweet of Jim. He's giving Dwight a pep talk. Okay. By the third time I watched it, I was like, some flippin' pep talk. I mean, this was like to press the hell out of me. Like, is this the speech you say? This is what he said. I mean, she was with Roy, right? Talking about Pam. And then he says, and I quote,
I just couldn't take it. I mean, I lost it Dwight. I couldn't sleep. I couldn't concentrate on anything. Even weird stuff like food had no taste. So my solution was to move away. It was awful. It was something that I wouldn't wish on my worst enemy pep talk. But Jim and Pam are together now. So is the rest of that scene that he's sort of saying like, listen, I've been where you are, but look where I am now, it's going to be okay. He just doesn't say that part. He doesn't say any of that. Yeah. He literally says, I wouldn't wish it on my worst enemy. And that includes you. And then he leaves. Well, he has to go kiss Pam. He has to go fall in love with Italian food. Yeah, he loves Italian food. I'm just saying, Jim, you're like speech to make him feel better.
You only delivered half of it. Yes. You needed the second half where it was like, buddy, look at me. I'm on the other side of it. I made it. We made it. You guys have a shot. Don't give up. Yes, that part is missing. Sorry, I'm still hot and bothered about John Wick. So I'm taking it out on Jim. I mean, I'm very sorry. Did you enjoy the films when you watched them at least? You watched all three. If you didn't like the first one, I can't imagine you would have watched two more just because I said, lady, I would not half ass watch something my friend told me to watch. Oh, well, I never finished Game of Thrones. I know. I couldn't do it. Okay, let's not salt in the wound. I'm sorry. I made you watch all of the John Wicks and I never finished Game of Thrones.
Well, I'm going to watch the fourth one now because now John Wick is pissed. Now he is. Oh, he's super pissed now. He seemed like he had a lot of reasons to be pissed after the first 45 minutes of the first film. Oh, yeah. Well, there's that. Well, he's got more ass to kick. And now he's going to be doing it with Laurence Fishburne. Oh, yeah. That's very interesting. Okay, where are we? Well, Jan has arrived. Oh, God. Oh, it's so good because Michael has run off. Oh, I will laugh so hard when she got out of the car and threw her keys at Oscar and hits him in the gut. Yeah. And when she throws her keys at Oscar at 38 minutes, seven seconds, you will see in the deep background Kelly and Daryl leaning on Daryl's truck talking. Now, is that where the deleted scene
would have gone? Were they talking by the dumpster? No, they weren't. So the deleted scene does happen in the warehouse and it would have happened around this time. But Kelly walks up to Daryl and says, hey, I made you an apology mix CD. Oh, an apology mix. And Daryl says, that's a lot of Michelle Branch. I'm never going to listen to these songs ever. And Kelly is kind of being flirty. She thinks they've made up and Daryl is like, listen, this doesn't fix things. So do you think the two of them standing by the dumpster is post deleted scene or pre deleted scene? It feels like it's post. I feel like it's post. I feel like they just decided to leave it more to chance, right? Sure. Well, Jan manages to find Michael. He is sitting on a train car. And she tells him,
listen, I'm here for you. No matter what you're going through, you were there for me. I'm there for you. It's kind of a sweet scene in their own way. It really is. And she's hilarious in it. She's like, listen, you were there for me when even my own family wasn't there for me. They're still not talking to me under the advice of council. Like what is Jan's family dynamic? Well, we had some fan questions from Catalina Rizzi, Hailey McCoy, Sophia Spear and Kate Walquist. They were all curious, where was Michael's train scene shot? Well, I'll tell you, it was not shot in the train yard by our set. It wasn't shot across the street. It was not. Wouldn't that have been convenient? It would have, but instead they drove all the way to Fillmore,
California, and they shot it at the Fillmore Western Railway. It's a little bit of info from Kentopedia. Thank you, Kentopedia. Back in the office, Dwight comes back to his desk. It looks like he has a new resolve, doesn't it? He kind of sits down and he gets on the phone. He's being assertive, making a call. He looks at Jim's desk and sees the pile of paper, grabs a ruler, starts shoving them back over, and Jim and Pam have this moment of like, well, Dwight's back. Yes. I have a little background catch I want to point out. Oh, me too. You go first. At 35 minutes, five seconds. We'll toggle back in time here, guys. There are no messy papers on Jim's desk when Angela is holding the squirrely cat. Yep. There's no messy papers. And then at 40 minutes,
37 seconds, when Dwight is about to shove everything aside, there are tons of papers, tons. Jim did so much work in that 10 minutes. And was messy about it? Very messy. Well, at 40 minutes, 32 seconds, piled up in front of Jim and Dwight's desks, there are a ton of boxes. Yes. And they are from Boise Cascade. And I just want to let you know that my dad worked for Boise Cascade in St. Louis, Missouri when I was a little girl. And he used to sometimes take me to work with him. And it was so fun. And we would eat in the cafeteria. And I would sit on the floor of his office and I would do coloring pages. But Boise Cascade, I was like, oh my gosh. And by the way, as a kid, we had tons of paper with the Boise Cascade watermark on it because
they sold paper. Was that just a coincidence, Jenna, that this company, it had nothing to do with you. It just happened to be there. Total coincidence. But I remember being on set and noticing this set decoration and then talking to those guys all about how my dad worked for that company. And it was sort of a fun thing then when my family would see the episodes. Yeah. And I'd be like, oh my gosh, dad's company, Boise Cascade. Oh, that's so cute. I never knew that. Yeah. Well, our final scene is this really sweet moment of Michael and Jan. They're walking off and Michael's saying, don't give back your implants. And she's like, I won't. I know you love them. And then they kind of have this back and forth. That was all improvised.
Amazing. They are so great together. They're so great together. What great acting partners, Melora and Steve. Yes. It is such a blessing when you get paired with someone who you have that kind of chemistry with. But they did such a good job casting the show. Alison Jones is just amazing. And we were all so lucky. So incredibly lucky. We say it all the time. We still feel lucky now. And we're just so thankful for you guys that listen in every week. We love this community. Jen, I just want to take a quick personal moment. This is our first episode back recording since before the holidays. And my family and I got sick over the holidays. We had COVID and it was a scary time. You know, the Office Ladies fans were so,
so supportive and kind and wrote me messages. The Facebook Office Ladies account did a whole video. And I watched it. My mom watched it. My husband and kids watched it. It was very moving for us to see this wonderful community. And it meant so much to me. I will never forget it. Angela, you shared that video with me. I cried because you're my best friend. And I know what that experience was like for you. And these loving messages, just the sweetest things. They're just saying like, lady, get better and sending pictures of hummingbirds to try to cheer you up. It's like, you know, it felt like a group of friends. Yes, it did. Reaching out, sending you just well wishes. And I have to say that the intimacy of this community is really real for us too. And yeah,
thanks for being there for my friend, you guys. Aw. Well, we will be here next week. We have a really special episode. Someone we're so thrilled to talk to. Randall Einhorn, our cinematographer and director from the office is going to be our special guest. And we are going to revisit everything we missed and deep dive with Randall. We'll see you guys then. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
For a free one-month trial of StitcherPremium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.